Hey, what's going on? It's bill bird. It's
the Monday morning podcasts for Monday,
September 9th, uh, 2013.
Is that what year it is?
2013. Absolutely it is. Um,
how's it going? How are you?
Did you have a good week?
I'm fucking out of it cause I had to get
up at five o'clock this morning and I
had to do a bunch of phones for
our upcoming shows, you know,
answering all the questions.
Some good, some bad,
some repetitive, but you know,
it's what you do as a professional.
The answer him every time, like it's the
first time. So, ah, how do you, well,
how do you come up with your
material? The is itself, the egg.
Do you write every day or is it
more spur of the moment? What?
Strike what strikes you as funny
and then you got to go into it.
Wow. Fucking, you know,
fucking teardrop coming out
of your eye. But um, whatever,
whatever. So here I am. I'm fucking
groggy. You knows. You know what sucks is,
I used to be a morning person.
I really did. But granted,
I also used to go to bed at like fucking
nine 30 10 o'clock at night because
when I was a young fella,
a little lad with orange hair
running around the playground,
try nice to get the shit kicked out of me
whilst bullying people smaller than me.
That's how you did it back then,
right? You beat the shit out of me.
I can't beat the shit out of you.
I have this awful feeling. Oh,
I'll take it out on that little
kid over there smaller than me.
That's the way it was done. It was the
70s there wasn't social networking.
Okay. People couldn't get
all get on and be like, Hey,
sign this petition man and let's
end the bullying. It wasn't,
you just had to go to school everyday
and you fucking took it and no local news
reporter came down and I didn't get
to go on the fucking TV with my stupid
freckled face, you know,
lower bottom lip quivering.
As I tell the story of somebody who
beat the shit out of me, nobody cared.
All right, that was it. So anyways,
now I'm in this fucking business
so I'm not a morning person.
I used to have a paper route. Everybody,
I get up at the crack of fucking dawn,
you know, jump on a bicycle, be
pitch black out in the wintertime,
freezing my fucking small balls off,
prepubescent,
prepubescent, and he said that
word fucking balls off, you know,
nostrils sticking together and
nobody gave a shit. This is,
this is back when a child did that job
that nowadays an adult has to do the job
either because the dollar is so fucking
weak or because that Chris Hanson has
everybody so paranoid that there's some
pervert with his dick out behind every
goddamn tree out there. That's
why you got fat kids. Right?
Did I do a bit about this back of
my fucking earlier standup days.
I can't even remember. I'm so tired right
now. But yeah, we still do that shit.
Parents didn't hover over, children
didn't have play dates, none of that shit.
What it was, was your mom fed you
and then there would be, you know,
she'd gets Sickey of bright around when
like the game show started coming on and
then she would just open the door and
just be like, you kids need to go outside,
go outside.
And you just go outside.
And there was other kids that were also
banished to God's side and then you'd
link up.
Hmm.
And then you just went
about your business.
You fought your tide kids to
trees you to fireworks. Adam, you,
you played with matches you
through shit and people's pools.
You vandalized a new house that was
being built, you know, sweet, innocent,
fun like huck Finn and Tom Sawyer.
That's what the fuck you did.
But uh,
those days are all gone to it.
Keep kids inside and you feed them and
you get a big and fat. That's what you do.
Well, that was the bidder. You get them
so fat that they're unfuckable. Right.
It's not what it was.
I can't remember what if there's a
pervert is into fat kids. You know,
it was a lot of holes in my
jokes this week. People. I'm
not gonna lie to you. Um,
so anyways,
I hope you guys had to go wake up.
Is it that NFL football's back
that, that, that, that photo photo?
Would you do put you do? Um, I actually
went to the, uh, the Denver Broncos.
Who the hell do they play?
The Ravens?
So I get into this big tex battle with
Paul Versey Paul verse. He's going like,
dude, it's a lock. Take Denver
given 10 points. It's a lot,
dude. I called it and all this
type of shit, right? Typical VRC.
And I'm sitting there going like, Paul,
it's the first week of the season.
Nothing's a fucking lock.
You have no idea. Okay.
You're throwing a fucking yacht and
you throw in a boat into the ocean.
All right? Is that if you an
expression. Um, but I like it.
Okay. If you can't do the math on that,
I can't fucking help you. All right.
Anyways, so he's telling me it's a fucking
lock it up. Just going like, you know,
10 points. I know ed reads not
there. I know Ray Lewis isn't there.
They still got a defense. They still got
Joe Flacco, they got ray rice. I mean,
ray rice can eat up a lot of God damn
clock. And as good as Peyton manning is,
if he doesn't have the ball, what
the fuck's he going to do? So, uh,
I, and another thing that bugged me was
everyone on ESPN was picks picking the
Broncos ball versus picking the Broncos.
Everybody I know was saying the
Broncos are going to kill him.
Like this fucking team wasn't
just in the Superbowl last year,
beaten the 40 niners getting
10 points. So I said, fuck it.
I think the ravens are going to win. We're
not, when I think that they're there,
they're going to cover.
And uh,
the first half when exactly
how I said it was going to go,
ray rice was running all over the place.
She went up the fucking clock.
Joe Flacco never looked good,
but he was looking good enough.
Defense had a big hit right in
the beginning, eh? Uh, thanks.
[inaudible] right. And then,
uh, the second half Cape,
and it was just, it was over.
Broncos are like, all right,
we can't run a,
let's go into a hurry up offense.
Joe Flacco looks like he hasn't thrown a
fucking ball since the last he threw in
the super bowl. He's got his
big contract, he got married,
let's say we a blitz them every other
play and see how he deals with this shit
and they fucking didn't
make any adjustments.
And I sat there watching one of the
greatest quarterbacks of all time have one
of the greatest performances of
all time and I could not enjoy it.
Just sitting there and knowing that Paul
Versey was going to be right and I was
going to be wrong.
And I was literally sitting there fuming
for like 24 fucking hours that the
fucking ravens had no answer to
the Broncos halftime adjustments.
The fact that I was fucking sitting
there with Paul Versey, I mean with,
with Jason Law head going like,
don't, the Broncos can't run the ball.
They should just fucking throw it now and
throw it to the sidelines because he's
fucking picking them apart.
It's exactly what the fuck they did.
I thought what's his face was going to
settle down. Jesus Christ. Joe Flacco,
I finally believe in the guy,
never believed in the guy.
I know it's only one week,
but he looked fucking horrific.
So I'm not saying he's going to be
horrific all year, but, uh, anyways,
long story short,
I had a great time and I really should
have enjoyed watching Peyton manning
throw for seven touchdowns cause that
was a legendary performance in any era,
even with the new rules of passing where
you just supposed to escort the fucking
a receiver down the field and get out
of the way when the quarterback under
throws him and shit,
it was still an unbelievable performance.
And I was actually had great seats and a,
he threw a couple of fucking balls.
Like they looked like they were
coming at our seats and you know,
the receiver came back and caught him.
He just got to see the speed of the NFL
and how fucking accurate manning was.
It was amazing to watch it if I
wasn't such a fucking grumpy cunt,
uh,
during the game.
MMM.
And I gotta tell you,
I actually enjoyed, uh,
watching the patriots trying to figure
out what we're going to do now on offense.
Now that Gronk has hurt and Hernandez
is looking at some serious jail time.
Uh,
I dunno, I actually enjoyed watching
them play the fucking bills.
I got to see a whole other level.
That's what it's going to be this year.
It's going to be a watching
Brady do what he does best,
which is make people
around him even better.
And that's what the
truly great ones can do,
you know?
And that's why I have issues with
some people that they say are great,
but they're just individually great. They
don't make people a better around them.
In fact, they borderline
annoy people around them.
Koby Bryant. Um, but you know,
I'm not going to name names, so, uh,
I don't know. We shall see. This
is going to be a tough season
for I think the Patriots. I don't know.
I don't how good we're going to be.
The sheer it is. It is early on, but uh,
but I'm all right with this is when you
actually become a true fan when your
team is in a fucking lock and a,
I liked that that quarterback that the
bills had ega manual. I liked effect.
Is that his last name?
I can't even remember.
But the fact that the guy can fucking run,
but uh,
he didn't seem like he only ran as
a latch as the last, like ditch.
Like I just got to fucking run.
He seemed like he tried to use his speed
more to stay in the pocket and thrill.
So a,
they look pretty God damn good to me.
And that's it for my boring ass football
talk. How'd you like that everybody?
How about a funny story bill?
All right.
Hop out the fact that I have a bruise on
my back the size of a fucking softball.
How'd you get that bill?
Well,
I decided to go hiking in the rocky
mountains and the beautiful state of
Colorado. I went up there with
Rosebowl legend Jason Law had,
you know, we went up there like we were
on a second date. Let's go on a hike.
Do you like hiking too?
I'm so excited.
So we decided to go on this fucking hike
and I'm nervous going into the rocky
mountains cause I, I'm thinking they
got bear, you know, fucking l Barracuda,
whatever the fuck they got up and there,
you know what I mean?
This is the real deal.
This isn't like the fucking Hollywood
hills out here where, you know,
I'm going to run into fucking Kevin
Bacon before I run into any sort of fuck.
You know,
I'm going to run into fucking
Louie depalma before I
run into even a bobcat out
here. That's all it is. Maybe
Lee majors visa in a bad mood.
Maybe you'll fucking
throw something at me.
That's the worst I have
to worry about out here.
These are the fuck can rocky mountains.
All right.
These are the mountains that they create
cause light with. This is the real deal.
So, um, we're going in there, you know,
with nothing but fucking, you know,
our workout clothes,
I have no weapon on me.
Everything is telling me
this is fucking stupid.
And,
uh,
we're in boulder, Colorado, which I'm
telling you, man, boulder, Colorado,
arguably the best,
the most in shape people I've
ever seen in my fucking life.
Yeah.
We were sitting there walking up this,
this, this hiking trail and we're all,
you know this, pardon me? I'm fucking
nervous cause I haven't gone up there.
I'm with somebody who hasn't gone up here.
This has all the makings of
one of those readers digest.
I almost fucking died stories
that they have in there.
And all of a sudden his fucking lady,
she had to be in her late fifties,
comes running down the trail.
People not walking,
running,
wearing those sneakers that look
like feet that are fucking annoying.
But you have to look at them
with this spring in her step.
Okay.
Like Walter Payton running on the balls
of her feet came running by barely
breaking a sweat. Big Smile,
fucking glow interface.
Hadn't let life beat her down or anything.
It was unbelievable.
And I'm like me and Jay, but at that
point we'd been in, we'd been in, um,
in boulder for like three days.
We did the show at the boulder theater,
did two shows. There were fucking
awesome, uh, unbelievable crowds,
great theater, a part of the Billy
red state tour, the rescheduled one.
And everybody showed up
and it was awesome. Uh,
the next day we went to the Broncos game
and then this was the morning we were
going to drive down to Colorado
Springs. We were like, well,
we got to work off all the booze.
We drank at the Broncos game,
so we decided to go on this
fucking hike. All right. All right,
I'm back on track here.
So we go into the,
into the wilderness with no weapons or
anything. And you know, I'm nervous.
I mean that lady run it by made me feel
good, but for half a second, I'm like,
cause she running from a mountain lion
because people where I'm from in their,
in their early thirties can't run
that fast. So we go up the hill and
it's just amazing. It's fucking
amazing. Like it's so beautiful.
You're like whispering like, oh
my God, look at those fucking,
I don't really have a view like that type
of shit. Right. But I'm also nervous,
like, uh, I just got this
feeling like, I don't know,
like I just don't want to get my face
ripped off. I mean, call me weird.
Call me a coward.
I don't give a shit.
Getting mauled is not on my bucket list.
Okay.
That just sounds so much
worse than getting stabbed
and shot because it like get
you need stabbed and shot from the,
unless you get riddled or stabbed
multiple times, for the most part,
you have a wound, but it's in one
area, one of your limbs, hearts,
the other three can
still use you get mauled.
That is just an all
encompass encompassing.
Like it's like you went through
a paper shredder. Alright,
I don't need that.
So,
okay.
We're, we're about half hour
into the hike and I'm like, wow.
I'm a half hour into the rocky
mountains with no fucking weapon.
And my guide is a fellow standup comedian.
So we decided to sit down on these
rocks. I'm like, let's sit down.
Just take a break because we're fucking
winded because we're middle aged guys,
we're out of shape and we're a mile
high in Denver or whatever folder.
So we sit down on these rocks and I'm
like nervous looking around making sure
there's nothing deciding
to fucking pounce on me.
And all of a sudden I hear a car
drive by and I'm like, what the fuck?
And like a hundred yards away,
there's like a road.
And then I looked over another 20 feet
and there was like a picnic table.
So I have a deli,
there's fucking trail we were going on.
This isn't like some deep forest
shit like we pulled off the road.
Evidently we could've just kept driving
and gone all the way up to the top.
So in the trail were on crosses
the road a couple of times.
So we're totally fine for the most part.
So I see the picnic table
and I pointed it to Jason.
We just start fucking laughing cause was
sitting down on these rocks like Lewis
and Clark and we're in the middle of
nowhere and we're, we're, we're fucking,
we're right there. We're in the middle of
silvers. Civilization. Long story short,
we get all the way up to the top.
Okay.
Um, we're standing on these rocks were
looking down, actually looking down into,
why was it Findlay
stadium, whatever, with uh,
the buffaloes play absolutely gorgeous,
was so high up,
we could see the Denver, the skyline
in Denver. It was fucking awesome.
So we start walking back and uh,
we're coming down the trail and it's
really loose kind of dirt and we keep
slipping, but we're all right. You
know, we keep regaining our balance.
At one point,
La had slips to the point where I thought
he was going down and then he was able
to recover. You know, he
was an athlete and I said, I
said, hey, go. That was nice.
You can see you, you know, you played hoop
yet, you've got an athletic background.
I said, had you been Joe de Rosa? Um,
I'd be carrying it down off the mountain.
And we were sitting there laughing at Joe.
Right?
Cause that's the kind of friend I am.
I throw my friends under the
bus when they're not there
to defend themselves. So,
okay.
When you know,
Karma comes back and bites me in
the ass like a fucking minute later,
I'm standing there taking a picture of
something and I go and I take a step or
two, dude, and I'm telling you,
it's like somebody took my legs out.
I didn't even know what happened.
I just fell and I landed on a rock.
Like first of all,
my,
my elbow scraped first on my
right arm and it pushed my,
it like hyper extended.
Like I almost snapped my fucking humorous
and all I was doing was falling from a
standing position down to
the ground in the dirt.
But they just happened to be this
fucking rock there. Um, and I almost,
and I think I would have broke it,
but fortunately the
rest of my body hit the,
the other part of the rock basically.
Just imagine jumping up in the air.
So you're horizontal and then just landing
on the rock with like a baseball size
part of your back. Dude, I
wish I could recreate the,
the fucking noise I made.
MMM.
And I,
that was it.
I was just down and I was down for
like a good 10 seconds, you know,
like when when somebody gets knocked
out or knocked down when that boxing and
they kind of sit back up at four seconds,
but they wait until the
nine and a half seconds.
Yeah.
Mark to fucking stand back up. That's what
I did and lie. I was going like, dude,
you are right. You are right. And I
kept saying, yeah and I wasn't. And uh,
so I start walking down the hill and um,
I'm kind of laughing because
I feel like a fucking idiot.
But laughing at this point hurts because
I guess you use those muscles in your
back Ed. Uh, I dunno.
About 30 seconds later la heads going,
yeah dude,
I can see blood coming through
your fucking tee shirt at a,
yeah, it was gross by the
time I got down to the bottom,
like my fucking tee shirt was
like stuck to my back and uh,
you know,
but it wasn't bleeding profile.
It was more like the cut was more like
a scrape because after I landed on the
Rock,
I then slid down it.
So I lifted up my shirt and I go,
how bad is it?
And I knew it was going to be
bad cause I knew what I did.
And not to mention I'm a pasty fucking
redhead and we don't bruise. We look like,
you know where somebody with pigment
would look like they had a bad bruise.
We look like we got bitten by
like a fucking Maaco Shark.
That's basically what I look
like. Um, and uh, you know,
I shook it off, went to the
pharmacy, got some Neosporin,
slapped it on my elbow, left it off
the back, figured it back was fine.
And then I went and I got a salad
and that was my fucking Denver Story.
How was that? So, uh,
my back has been killing me the last
couple of days and a, it's weird when I,
the only time it hurts is when I go
to stand up and I got to make a noise.
I'll make the noise for you here. Let
me see if I can get it. It hurts. Oh,
of course. Now it doesn't hurt. I think
I did it. I freed it up. All right.
That was a big, that was like
Geraldo looking into that
safe. Sorry about that. Um,
anyways, let's get to some fucking
advertising for this week. Every one.
I know this is kind of a
disjointed podcast this week. Uh,
cause I got up early with a fuck. Is it?
Oh, for Christ's sake, Bill, come on,
come on. Can we do this? All right.
Dollar Shave club, everybody, you know,
there is so many things in the world
that irritate me. Um, you know, slipping,
falling on a rock, inconsiderate con, uh,
the fact that I have a motorcycle license,
but I'm too scared to get one and drive
one down the street. Well, actually no.
You know what, considering what just
happened to me from a standing position,
I can't imagine going 40 miles an
hour and falling on the tar. Uh,
that bugs me not being able to
gas your own people. You know,
what's the world coming to, uh, when
so many things can irritate you.
Why add razors to the list.
It's time to stop milking your razor
blade. I know with brand name razors,
you used to paying
outrageous prices and x,
so then you then exhaust those razors
until they start to look like a rusty soda
can. It's time to move on. Everybody.
Dollar Shave Club delivers amazing
quality blades to your door for just a few
bucks a month.
Never think about it again.
They send a pack every month so you
can change your blades every week. Uh,
I love these guys and your
face is going to love him too.
They've always got an uh,
fucking come on bill.
They always got a new product all.
They also got a new product
called one wipe Charlies.
It's a but wipe for men and it's classy
as opposed to those unclassy butt wipes.
You know the ones I'm talking about?
Check out the video for that and
sign up for your racers today.
Go to dollar shave club.com forward
slash burr. That's dollar shave club.
Com forward slash burr or go to bill
bird.com and click the dollar shave club
banner and a what's next?
Hulu plus everyone.
I'm sure you've tried hulu.com but I
want to tell you about Hulu plus who plus
less. You watched thousands
of hit shows anytime,
anywhere streaming on your TV or
go with your smart phone or tablet.
Why stand in line or ride a train
and just stare at your feet.
You could be watching your favorite shows
on Hulu Plus who plus is a great way
to Binge Watch your favorite shows to
Hulu plus has tons of episodes from great
comedies like SNL community,
modern family, South Park,
family guy in thousands of other shows.
Plus it's only seven 99 a month.
That's seven 99 for all the
shows and movies you can watch.
Catch up on current shows, binge on an
old favorite or catch a great movie.
You can do it all on Hulu plus right now.
You can try Hulu plus for a
couple of weeks free on me.
When you go to the podcast page at
[inaudible] Dot Com and click on the Hulu
plus banner or go to Hulu plus.com/bill
please make sure you use the Hulu
plus.com banner.
I mean book plus who plus.com/bill link
so you can get an extended free trial.
And so they know that we sent you, helps
make us a little bit of money, right,
puts fruit loops on my table
and gives you a great day.
One more time for extended free trial,
Hulu plus.com/bill what else do
we got here? Um, yeah, that's it.
That's good for the advertising for the
moment. You know, I touched on there,
I mentioned some of that
serious stuff about them. Uh,
so theoria are you Syria?
Um,
I mentioned that, uh, you know, what's
the deal there? That they got a little,
uh, against some shit there
for gas and their own people.
I don't understand that whole thing of
if you don't sign a treaty saying that
you're not going to guess other
people or I guess maybe they did.
I tried to figure out whether they did
or not and I got onto this colored map of
the world where they had
people who signed it,
people who signed it and said to hell
with it and people who never signed it and
then people who sort of signed it and
there was all these colors and these
graphs. I can't figure out
if they signed it or not,
but let's just say for the sake of the
argument that they went to the Geneva
protocol in 1949 and they decided that
they were going to sign that thing and
they weren't going to gas people.
Now as far as how it's written,
isn't it written that basically
you're not going to get,
you don't guess our people and we
won't guess your people, but is,
is there anything in there that
says you can't gas your own people?
We're not saying you can, you should do
it, but those are your people. Right?
Like if I go out and buy
myself a new outfit, you know,
to show off my thick. Yeah,
there's nothing preventing me. Says I
can't go out and go jump in a mud puddle.
Right. This is my fucking clothes. Now,
if I take those clothes off and then
throw them in some old lady's face now,
now there's a problem. But if I
just roll around in that mud puddle,
I'm just doing damage to myself,
aren't I?
I don't fucking know how dumb
do I sound right now? Well,
you know when you're done tow, fuck
you. It's a legitimate question.
I don't understand why you can't
gas people. He can't do that.
But you can fucking firebomb
cities and you can straight people.
You know you can do area bombing. Oops.
Did that land on a nursery with babies?
Why can you do that? You know what it
is? I think it's too easy. I get it.
Chemical weaponry. That's like the
PE Dee of of mass murder. All right.
No, just send. That's what it is.
Being able to gas people, that's like
everybody gets their own ribbon. Okay.
You know what, I worked at out,
you don't need to write in,
but if you want to write in,
I'd love to talk about it.
Something fucking
different as you see that,
that story ESPN had that they ran with,
I guess very little facts
at least according to the
very pissed off woman that I
wrote,
I read her little article about it.
They were trying to claim that Bobby
Riggs through that match against Billie
Jean King. I'm showing
my age here. I mean,
I don't remember when this shit happened,
but back in the 70s,
they had the battle of the sexes
and Bobby Riggs, a former champion,
55 fucking years old,
plays Billie Jean King 29,
the number one seated woman's
player in the world at the time.
And uh,
he played her and he lost.
And evidently that was some sort of
big thing for women that a woman in her
prime could beat an old man at Tennessee.
So now somebody was trying
to claim that was fixed.
It sounded like bullshit that he threw
the match because the saying that I guess
he played the number two woman in
the world and beat her handily.
But there's a big difference between
number two and number one as you saw
yesterday with a Serena and uh,
what's her face that she played?
They fucking battled for the first two
sets and then Serena just took over.
It was like, fuck this. You know,
it's so fucking hilarious about Serena
Williams is when she's playing tennis.
I swear to God, it's just raw. Like
she doesn't make too many noises,
but she just looks like I would
duck if she hit the ball. You know,
it's like a fucking linebacker out there.
Right.
But then the second she wins the match,
she turns into a girl again, like,
oh my God, she, if it's like our
one hand up and starts waving,
jumping up and down, really girly,
like, but when she's playing the game,
I swear to God,
it's like she could fucking kill somebody.
So she's playing this other
lady and I'm telling you,
they were playing like dude's,
there was some volleys to couple times.
They went to the net,
but pretty much they would just
at the baseline, just power shots,
fucking home run hits.
I'll tell you,
I was watching the packers 40 niners
and I started flipping over just to see,
you know, I mean, how often do you get
to see a legend? Plain. I mean, she went,
she just want her 18th major I think so
she's closing in on Steffi Graf and then
after Steffi Graf, is that Australian
broad? I forget her name. I know the guy.
What is it? Not Stan Smith. Rod
Laver. He's won the most of any guy.
The fuck's her name,
Margaret or meg.
She's got some one of those
old people fucking m names,
so she's closing in on her.
So I wanted to watch a little bit of
that and it was a fucking great match.
I had a fuck that I get on with this,
but whatever that is,
you know that that's always bugged me.
That Bobby Riggs thing,
when Billie Jean beat Bobby Riggs,
like that proves something.
See Women in the prime of their life are
just as good as men whose Dick's don't
really work anymore
and are in the early stages of prostate
cancer. They can beat us at badminton,
a faster game of badminton. So I dunno,
so some, some woman wrote this article,
you know, it doesn't matter
whether it was fixed or not,
it doesn't matter any more.
Like the problem with women is they
actually give a shit what guys say,
you gotta be like, guys, if you
really want to become free of men,
this is what you have to do.
Two things.
You have to stop giving
a fuck what we say.
You have to talk down to us more.
And then what you have to do is
you have to start your own shit.
The problem with women,
how many my pissing off right now
is you keep trying to join our shit.
You know,
we have a gym,
we have the water buffaloes club
and there's no women allowed.
You should be like, great,
get the fuck out of the house.
Go down there the same way we would do
you think we give a fuck that you'd have
a women's only gym?
Go down there,
do a double session, get the
fuck Outta, I don't care.
Especially now with all these
great ways of tape and TV,
you can watch all these fucking games
by all means. You know, beat it.
Beat it. Right? You don't
just get Outta here, you guys,
you got to start having that
fucking attitude because that's,
that's,
that's the genius of guys is we act like
we don't give a fuck about you but we
till, but we act like we don't and we
act like what we're going to go do.
We're excited about it.
And you guys drink that Koolaid and
you actually think what we're doing is
exciting. So you want to become a part
of it. You want to join a dump gyms,
right?
You want to join a fucking golf clubs
because you think there's something going
on that you think you're actually
missing out on something you're not.
She punches stupid guys walking
around scratching at Dick's.
Every other fucking sentence.
Why would you want to be around them?
I don't want to be up on a bunch of women,
like I don't even know what
you guys talk about. To me,
it sounds like a bunch of birds
fighting over a French fry.
I don't want to listen to that
shit. All right. I love art.
Like I'm berating a guys out
of fucking nowhere. I thought,
I thought I was beyond this in my life.
Evidently I'm not.
Um, all right, let's plow ahead
here. Everybody. You know what?
I did this this week.
I really watched the offensive
line of the New England patriots.
That's what I did.
And uh,
I actually liked what I saw it,
man.
I thought they were protected time really
well. And I think if you're a true,
if you're a true football fan,
if you're to true your team,
you should know your offensive line to
the point where you're actually recognize
them when they go down the street.
You know,
if you actually know what who, what Ryan
Wendell looks like, where Dan Klein,
Lee Logan Mankins,
nobody knows these fucking
guys need sold my AA. Not,
they've seen the fucking names where,
cause you never hear him. You know why?
Because they never get busted
for holding Sebastian Vollmer.
Right.
I actually paid attention to the offensive
line this week was the first time in
30 years of watching football,
35 fucking years.
I actually noticed in the
huddle how they're lined up,
how the offensive line is lined up,
where they just turn right around there,
right in position. And it's like,
of course they are bill you dumb.
Fuck the clock is ticking.
What do you think?
They just all go into the
huddle all willy nilly.
Is that because you never played organized
football? I played for a few weeks.
I actually played for a few weeks.
This is kind of a sad story.
And then Darryl Stingley got paralyzed
and my parents got freaked out and they,
they, uh, actually I've got
to tell you, uh, you know,
they had the foresight to see what I was
doing in my brain playing football and
they also saw my athletic abilities. So
it's just like, you know, they were like,
he's already kind of dumb and,
uh,
he's not the most athletic person,
so why would we want them to sit here
smashing his head to another third graders
head? Let's have him play baseball game.
Hey about those red sox. Huh? God dammit.
I wish I was watching baseball this year.
You know, excited. I would be,
I'm not going to lie to you.
I'm going to jump on the
band wagon come October.
I always watch October baseball.
Anyways. I love it. Like,
I don't know if they have
extra microphones or whatever,
but there's just the sounds of the
ballpark is better. But uh, you know,
take it three out of four from the
Yankees. That's pretty fucking impressive.
And I,
and I really am kind of amazed at the
fact that that trade with the Dodgers
worked out for both teams.
That's so rare and a blockbuster trade
that it works for both people that should
have been like great for one team and
horrific for the other or as certain as
such for both teams. Like that's what
usually happens in a blockbuster trade.
Either works for nobody. I bill, you just
said it. You don't need to repeat it,
but very rare does it work
out for football teams?
I don't know why those superstars
started playing for the Dodgers,
but I'm glad they did. I've always liked
the Dodgers and uh, I'm glad that we,
uh, saved a bunch of fucking money in
whoever the hell we have on our team.
He's evidently playing fucking great.
Could I say evidently one more
fucking time this podcast? Um,
evidently I can shoot,
uh, let's plow ahead here.
Uh, oh, I was watching some
greater youtube videos last night.
Um, I've become obsessed. Let me see.
I don't even know his fucking name is
great. I've become obsessed with them.
I don't even know his fucking name.
Where the hell is it?
A for God's sakes,
what the fuck is this guy's name?
You know what?
I just, this is, this is why right here.
I at some point need to bring somebody
else into the fucking fault so I can
actually,
okay,
where is it? Here we go. Put this
on here and then we hit mute.
So enough to pay any money
for the fucking song.
Okay.
With a,
God dammit all there it is.
I become obsessed with this drummer,
raw James Gadson.
He basically, a lot of people,
if you're a bill withers fan,
I highly recommend downloading us.
Still still bill.
That's incredible fucking album.
Bill withers is one of the greatest
singers of all time and I also think
unbelievably underrated as a singer.
And uh,
he's got this killer drummer James
Gadson and just, I don't know,
that guy just doesn't get the attention
he deserves. So long story short,
I started,
you know,
youtube and him and watching him
play does not a lot of stuff on them.
There's a lot of,
uh,
videos and shit of interviews with them
and that led me to one of those great
youtube runs. Well, you
don't end up on a slap fight.
You actually stuck to learn stuff.
And I came across this other drummer,
okay.
Like Fred, Fred Bellow of, I don't
know how to say his fucking name,
which led me to this concert film
and Otis rush singing, I
can't quit. You baby. Um,
that led Zeppelin raids did a remake
of called, I can't quit you babe,
as opposed to I can't quit you baby.
So that's how they switched it up.
And then that's why they never paid Otis
rush until they settled out of court.
I don't know if that's true, if they
had to settle out of court with them.
I know they had to do that a
couple of times. But uh, Otis Rush,
one of the greatest live singers I ever
heard and he plays guitar lefthanded and
he doesn't string it.
He plays a right hand and guitar upside
down and did not string it the other way.
He just plays it upside down strong,
right handed.
And the only other guy I knew who
did that was, uh, was Dick Dale.
I didn't know there was someone else who
did it, but he's fucking unbelievable.
I'm going to send you a link to
this concert concert film, uh,
the podcast this week cause
you really should see it.
It should know about this guy, a case
you don't know about them. And, uh,
and also I want to know what concert does,
is if anybody has any information on it
and how somehow I can watch the whole
concert because it's crazy.
It starts with, you know,
this older black dude who's like playing
like Boogie woogie piano and he see
he's part of that generation and then it
kind of leads into these guys who were
more R and B guys and it's right before a,
okay.
I Dunno, it seems, it's
like right around that time,
right as James Brown was
coming out or whatever.
But it's just a great period where
people can actually play music and shit,
play instruments and sing live.
It's fucking awesome. And then the,
they're playing performing of course,
to this horrific white crowd that is just
sitting there like their entire lives
have been mapped out in front of them
and they made no decisions and they have
no passion in life. I don't know what
it is. It's fucking embarrassing,
but it's incredible concert footage. All
right. I'm done. Run in my fucking mouth.
Let's go to, uh, let's go to some of your
questions and information this week. Uh,
I got a ton of shit last
week by saying a port,
a pork shoulder was
actually the ass of the pig.
I guess it actually is the shoulder.
I guess a Christmas Ham is the ass
or you can eat it on thanksgiving.
Just say Ha. Ham is the ass of the pig. So
this guy says, Bill, I love your podcast.
I'm a former butcher and I wanted to
correct you on your smoke shoulder comment
on yesterday's podcast. A pork shoulder
is the front shoulder on a pig.
The confusing part is they are also
called pork butts. It's not the,
but the butter. The pig is
the ham. Hope this helps.
Um, blah, blah, blah. Well, you
know, what can you write back?
Why do they call it a, but
then I have no idea why.
Why do they call it that? All I know is
it's fucking delicious. As is the acid.
The pig.
I eat the whole fucking pig.
Wherever the fuck the Bacon
is, you know, that'd be,
do they have classes like that?
Do they have a class that teaches you how
to butcher an animal in case you know,
whenever the dollar collapses
and I'm out there, I mean,
I know how to shoot a bow and arrow.
Now I know how to fucking
gut a fish pretty well,
but I'd like to know how to fucking
shoot a wild pig. Hey, fuck this.
I'm on the Billy red state tour people.
I'm coming out to El Paso.
I'm coming out to San Antonio. If anybody
out there it goes wild boar hunting.
I want to do that shit.
I want to do it,
but I don't want to fucking kill one just
for the sake of killing it. All right?
I want to fucking kill it. Clean
it, do the whole fucking thing.
You make me do all of this shit.
Uh,
I know animal lovers out there
probably don't like it. I'm,
I'm doing it not to do it all the
fucking time. I want to have that skill.
All right? Basically, I'm slowly,
I want to become macgyver.
I want to not firing on to shoot a fish
with a bow and arrow sort of. Okay.
I know what a loaded gun
and shoot it sort of,
I got some vegetables growing and Rhonda,
my house Kinda.
So if I know how to take down a
fucking pig, got that fucking thing,
it's got to translate to a god damn deer.
Right.
Sort of the same shit I would think.
Yeah.
Then all I to do was get a helicopter
license and I'm good to go.
I know how to ride a motorcycle now.
You see what I'm saying?
So you got fucking,
if he have a helicopter that like what
I love about the helicopter is you just
go right up.
You can escape so easily.
It's almost like you literally know
how to fly. We're like, you know,
with an airplane you need that run and
start, you know. Oh fucking though.
But anyway, so somebody who wants
to take me wild boar hunting,
I would fucking do that.
And as second I go down to ll
bean and show of my brand new,
I'm going hunting shit,
looking like fucking, you know,
like those old Vietnam movies when you
first get there and you buckle your Chin
strap to your helmet.
And then all of grizzled veteran
veterans tell you not to do it.
Cuts the concussive force of the shells
is gonna blow your fucking head off.
That type of stuff. But what are
you talking about? I don't know.
I want to shoot a pig,
you know, fucking great. That would be,
take that fucker down. Wait. Alright.
Take that fucker down.
Clean it.
Bring the fucking meat home and
then smoke it on my fucking grill.
How much of a man I would feel like how
much cowardice I could fucking push down
that I have the pussy.
Pardon me would really be shut down
and I wouldn't have to listen to those
voices in my head.
And for a few minutes I could actually
act like I was actually a stud.
Yeah.
Hey, fuck you. I have my dreams,
you know. All right. Whatever.
40 minutes. Then here we go. This time
to read some, some of your letters. Uh,
seriously. Fuck your American
sports. Another positive email here.
Hi Bill. Big Fan. Got Tickets to
see you in London in December.
I got to take a time out here. Ah,
the response to a, some of my shows,
pretty much all of them over there
has been unbelievable in Europe.
And I can't thank you guys enough.
Uh, we added a show in London,
added a show in Helsinki.
How crazy is that?
And some promoter and
Astonia just asked me to add,
I'm not going to be able to do it this
time, but I'm doing it next time. And uh,
it's been unbelievable.
So, uh, I'm really,
really excited to go over there.
I'm going to and this time rather than
just go in there and landing and, uh,
you know, being a Zombie during the
day, I'm coming over like three, three,
four days early to, uh, get acclimated.
I'm going to actually go to Italy. I
haven't decided where yet, but, uh,
I'm just going to go there and eat
okay.
And,
uh,
I'm going to try and see an opera when
I'm there and some old opera house.
I don't have too much time to go there.
I don't think I want to go to Rome
and go to the see the Roman Colosseum.
I feel like that's going to times square.
That's what I've learned in my travel.
You like, you go to New Orleans, I
guess you have to see Bourbon Street,
but you really don't
want to be down there.
That's just a bunch of drunk tourists
which you want to go down is uh, you know,
you know what, I'm not going to
tell you the cool places to go.
You gotta go there and talk to the
locals cause I don't want to fuck up the
locals. Good places to go.
It's kind of like, you know,
I stayed at one of the greatest fucking
hotels I've ever stayed at when I was in
Colorado and uh,
I'm not going to tell you guys where it is
because I don't want to ruin it.
If you just by dumb luck
discover it is fucking amazing.
We stayed at this place
if for dinner we had lamb,
an elk,
and uh,
and was this quiet town off the beaten
path and they had this little fucking bar
that we went to.
We're like,
the bartender wasn't even behind the bar.
She was over in the middle of shooting
pool. One of those kinds of things.
And for the first time in my life,
like country music made sense.
I finally realized, I knew Willie Nelson
was good. I didn't know he was that good.
All right.
And I went up to the fucking jukebox and
I just started every fucking legendary
country guy that I knew.
You know,
I throw in a couple of fucking rock
songs or whatever, but you know,
Merle Haggard, all these guys
and I, and I wouldn't pick,
they'd have their greatest hits.
I wouldn't go off that. I go off,
I pick a different album then pick like
the third track rather than the first
track. Cause they usually
lead with the radio hit.
I wanted to hear something different
dude. And I fucking loved it. So, uh,
but then when it was weird,
I got to La and I tried to download some
Willie Nelson and didn't feel the same
way, you know, so I'm going
to download some fucking,
some of that shit for my drive from
El Paso to San Antonio this week.
Uh, play in El Paso on Thursday
and then San Antonio on Friday.
Uh, there's still some
tickets left in El Paso.
I mean they picked a really
big place because, uh,
it was either play a little place,
there was data,
they didn't have the middle ground one.
So we just picked a big place.
I don't know if they're going to
close out the balcony, whatever,
but there's definitely tickets left.
Um,
but then after that I
drive down to San Antonio,
listen to this fucking amazing week.
And then Saturday I'm hanging around and
I'm going, me and oversee of going on.
A couple of other buddies were going to
go to the, uh, Texas a and M Alabama game,
going to go see Johnny football go
up against one of the great fucking
college football teams.
I mean that the run that Alabama's on
his fucking insane being an Lsu fan and
fucking annoys the shit out of me.
But, uh, you can't not appreciate it.
So we're going to go to that game and
that's going to be our week. So, uh,
anyways, so I'm trying to do more of
that type of stuff when I do the road.
And as a comic it's great because you
get excited to go on the road when you
plan shit like that and it, if
you're excited, you don't dry up,
you just don't start hating your act and
you don't end up like just saying fuck
it and hosting a game show,
not to say there's anything with that.
And not to say that I
would never host a game,
show them that might become a point my
fucking career where I just can't do it
anymore. And I'll go on and
I'll fucking host card sharks.
The dope card sharks with
bill burr all a bit higher.
You got arrest all of it. Here
we go. And that can be fun.
You know what's great about
being a game show host?
You know you got a fucking fat ass fucking
house with an in ground pool and at
that point who gives a shit,
right?
And every fucking woman who comes on
the show, they fucking, they, they,
they, I don't know. They make
you feel special. Oh my God.
I watch his show every day.
Fucking kiss you on the cheek,
or you can be a pervert like Richard
Dawson and kiss him on the mouth. Man. Uh,
who knows? I might do that. When I get a
little older, I still got some fight me.
All right. This business hasn't
dragged me in the boat yet.
I'm on the hook without a doubt.
They're reeling me in,
but I'm not on the boat yet. They haven't,
they haven't fucking club me yet. So, um,
yeah,
so that's my thing.
I'm going to go to fucking Italy
and I'm going to go see an opera.
Bring a little fucking handkerchief
there and hope I actually,
it moves me rather than
sitting there going like,
dude, I don't get what they're
talking about. Why? See, so fat dude,
that skinny chick would never
hook up with that fat guy.
I don't want to be that dude. So anyways,
let's get to the question here. Uh,
I'm in the UK,
I listen to your podcast and I hear the
names of these little teams and games
that you have, uh, that you have there.
So last night I'm going to bed and um,
I've been slowly growing this tiny amount
of gambling money, just small change,
just so just for fun.
And I thought I'd drop it on him.
I drop it on a banker that was played
while I slept and then I have a little bit
of interest in the morning. Okay.
This guy. So I like this guy. He's,
he's doing his little train spotting slang
here and I'm trying to figure it out.
Drop it on a bank or,
I mean,
do you want to put money on the game so
you putting up money on a game overseas
and while you're asleep and you're
going to wake up and see if you made any
money or not. Wow. Dude,
you just took gambling to a whole of year
of fucking international gambler dude.
You have like a fucking white Tuxedo that
you get up and put on like Roger Moore.
Okay.
That's kind of fucking fun.
That's actually, you know, for people
to have a serious gambling problem,
they probably didn't need to know that
because the only time of serious gamblers,
not gambling is probably when he's going
to sleep. This mother Fucker is sin.
So God damn DP figured
out a way though it,
I commend you and I also feel bad for you,
sir. That's fucking amazing. So anyways,
he goes,
I went to my bookmakers,
but bookmakers site inside the Yankees
being the Red Sox, eight to three,
they were giving odds on the Red Sox,
nine to one in a two horse race
and a one to 100 on the Yankees.
So I put the equivalent of $30 on
the Yankees and thought, ah fuck,
it's an extra 30 cents I'll
have in the morning. So wait a,
you can bet on a game
that's already going.
So it's eight to three
two,
why wouldn't you take in the fucking, oh,
you did take the Yankees, right? Wait,
the Yankees were being the red sox. Eight
to three I got, oh, I'm dumb people.
I get to work this out. They were giving
odds on the red sox nine to one. Okay,
so you got to put up 900 bucks to make a
hundred at that point or $9 to make one
bill. They took out the Zeros,
they tried to make it easy for you.
And then the Yankees, you throw down
a dollar, you can make a hundred
so you said fuck it. There's no
way the Yankees are going to lose.
And let's see, you could have made 30
cents. You put down what? 300 bucks?
Is that how it works? What'd you
put down? Three, three bucks.
You put down three bucks. It's cheap.
Fuck your bitch in about three bucks
a fucker. What's going on in this? So
anyways, he said, what? What the fuck?
Sort of Mickey Mouse Bullshit team or
the Yankees to fuck that up so bad.
It's brutal.
Losing 30 well 30 bucks,
losing 30 bucks trying to win 30
cents do the math doesn't oh yeah,
that's right. That's right.
Yeah. Okay, great. 30 cents.
Imagine I could be fighting in a war
alongside you guys with a bag of live hand
grenades on my back. Yeah, dude,
I don't know how you made the lept
from the leap from fucking, uh,
that game to fighting in a war.
Yeah.
I don't know what kind of fucking asshole
goes to sleep trying to make 30 cents
serves your right. Your cheap fucker. You
should have bet the under dog. Oh wait,
you did? No you didn't.
You bet the favorite. Well,
you know what your deal is,
you guys overseas, all you know is
the Yankees the same way over here.
All we know is a,
what the fuck are they a man United?
That's the only team we know. I mean, I
know some of the arsenal, uh, or arsenal,
I don't know Liverpool,
but I don't know what they're called.
I just know man United, Manchester
United. That's all I fucking know.
And you know what?
I don't like them cause this shit's
over here and they're like the fucking,
I dunno. I don't want, I don't like the
team that everybody likes, you know,
fucked him. So I'm sorry sir. I'm sorry.
You lost $30 trying to make 30 cents.
Would that even by a half a fucking cup
of tea or whatever the fuck you going to
do over there by your one chip for
your fish and chip fucking breakfast.
Um, anyways, but either way, dude,
thanks for buying tickets to the uh,
the London show. Uh, like I said,
it really is humbling to have that.
If I can use that fucking
phrase without getting trashed,
it really is that people over there
give a shit and want to come out.
So I hope I'm funny. I'm all
right. Ken Burns. Dear Billy boy,
I heard you talking about the Ken Burns
documentary recently and why don't you
turn on,
turn you on to one of his documentaries
that I've yet to see but I hear is great.
Um, and for those of you
have been listening the past
few weeks, I've been slowly,
when I have the time getting
through a Ken Burns the war,
it's all about World War II.
I think I'm through five episodes.
It's a seven part series and it
is absolutely fucking incredible.
The footage.
I think a lot of the footage,
like they wouldn't show
for the longest time,
like the really shows the, uh, it's,
it's not a propaganda film.
Put it that way. It's,
it's an absolutely
astounding thing to watch.
It's so amazing. It's actually
caused me to, I'm starting to read,
not only read but read about the war and
for dummy like me to actually want to
go out and start reading books.
Um,
although I had to take a break because it
was so fucking heavy, some of the shit,
uh, than, uh, right now I'm reading a,
that guy from ministry and reading his
autobiography and if you want to feel
better about some of the
choices you've made in life,
like maybe you think I'm a piece
of shit. I did this, I did that.
I partied too much.
You got to read this guy's book.
You're going to feel like you don't have
any sort of substance abuse problem.
I'm not shitting on the guy.
The guy's a fucking genius. Um,
and I'm totally late to the party when
it comes to great music from the 80s.
I listened to so much shit
music in the 80s, and uh,
I completely missed out on all this
amazing stuff that was going on.
Ministry being one of them. And what's
funny is the song that I liked the best,
he hates and says he hates it because
the people who like it or like people who
were into metal, uh, it's
Stigmata I fucking love it.
And I like it because it sounds like a
metal song with all this in a industrial
shit. Don't, I don't even
know anything about it.
He would cringe if he heard any of this,
but I actually had to put the book down
and started laughing cause he totally
called me out as I'm reading
the book. Uh, he used to say no,
there was just a throwaway song.
But anyways,
it's on this album called the land of rape
and honey, which is an avid, it was a,
I guess as a fucking classic and I never
heard anything about it because I was
listening to Motley Crue theater
of pain when that came out.
Um, so anyways, so he says,
let me get back to this.
So he says, Ken Burns has another great
documentary. By the way, I'm watching all,
I'm watching all of Ken Burns'
documentaries, uh, on Netflix. Uh, I've,
I'm doing civil war next, but this
guy's actually suggesting, uh, he's, uh,
there's a new one called prohibition.
He goes,
I haven't seen it yet because I'm in
the middle of a book about prohibition,
but I find the whole subject fascinating,
not only because it talks about how
the majority of the working class were
drunks,
but it gets all into the politics and
cultural issues associated with drinking
back in the day and how the
breweries changed America. Also,
Merck also,
there are many similarities to the
whole weed movement we see nowadays. Uh,
did you ever find yourself in a dry
county or a state where you can't find a
beer in the grocery store with some of
our alcohol related laws can be traced
back to prohibition and the crazy shit
that caused it are drunk and forefathers.
Uh, you know, it's funny, dude,
you're just like me. You spent,
you spelled fore fathers, f, O,
u, R as in one, two, three, four.
Isn't it for free? I don't
know. Fuck it now. Uh,
our drunken forefathers would get out of
their industrial jobs at the end of the
day. Look to decompress a bit and
stay in pubs all night. Soon enough,
these guys started bringing home STDs to
their wives and banging all the horrors
that also stayed in the pubs all night.
Their wives started getting upset and
fast forward a bit and then you have
prohibition. Some guys just
ruined it for everyone really.
Well, I knew it kind of came out of
the church. Uh, I didn't know that.
I just heard somebody say
that and I took it as law. Um,
thanks for the heads up
and thanks to everybody.
Seriously when you guys
write in yet, actually, yeah,
I know we fuck around a lot of this thing,
but when you have something there that
will actually make you a more informed
person or actually it's a
great piece of entertainment.
Please send it my way because I would
like to do rather than just give out bad
advice to you guys,
I would like to actually try to make
your lives a little bit better on some,
on some level, and you know what? Here's
a great way to make your lives better.
People legal zoom
snuck that one in a on any snuck that
one in on you did night. Can you tell?
I've been up since five in the morning.
I can't even talk. A lot of prides.
Legal Zoom,
everybody.
A lot of pride comes along with starting
your own dream business. Absolutely.
I couldn't agree more legal zoom,
but think about the stress you feel if
you don't take the right steps to legally
protect your business and personal
assets from the beginning.
That's why I William Burr recommend the
legal zoom.com during the past 12 years,
over a million businesses,
business owners have trusted legal
zone to help start their business.
Legal Zoom will save you a lot of
time and money, not only money,
a pile of money on startup costs.
Plus they'll provide solutions to
help you run a successful business.
Legal Zoom can provide self
help services at your specific,
your specific direction or
connect you with an attorney,
but they are not a law firm.
Just to let you know,
just go to legalzoom.com today to
see what to see what's right for you.
Form an LLC, get a Dba,
incorporate a form,
a nonprofit all starting at just 99 bucks.
Plus you'll save even more when you enter
bur bur in there for in the referral
box at checkout. That's legalzoom.com
promo code [inaudible] one more time.
legalzoom.com Promo Code [inaudible].
Um,
is that it? Oh No, I missed
one here. He voice everyone.
If you're an entrepreneur, if you're
an entrepreneur and a customer calls,
do you want to seem like you're
in a high rise window view?
Let's start this one again. Shall
We? Let's give a voice to read.
They deserve he voice everybody.
If you're an entrepreneur
and a customer calls,
do you want to seem like you're
in a high rise window view,
fancy pants office or do you want them
to know you're sitting in your underwear?
I think that's an easy one,
right? With your eve voice. Um,
you can create the appearance of an
entire building, sales, customer support,
tech support, you name it. It's
going to seem like you have it.
Give your customers the royal
treatment with the voice.
He voice will forward
business calls to your home,
mobile or any number you choose.
Wherever you are, he voice.
We'll find you don't have time
to take a call. No problem.
It's routed to your voicemail and you
can read it at your convenience as an
email if you like. He voiced not only
gives you an edge over your competitors,
it takes away the edge the big companies
have over you right now and now you can
try.
He voice for free for 30 days,
one whole month unless it's a month to
31 days, but they make it up in February.
Go to [inaudible],
voice.com and use Promo Code Bill B I l.
L that's [inaudible]
dot com Promo Code Bill.
Or just go to the podcast page at
[inaudible] dot com and click on the voice
banner. There you go. Those are
the ads for this week. All right,
let's get back to some of your
questions here or your information. Um,
hairy situation is what this
one is called. All right.
What are you guys thinking?
Hairy situation here that did something
he shouldn't have done and he's waiting
for the other shoe to drop or a, he hooked
up with a beautiful girl who's going,
oh, natural rail. Old Age. All right.
Hey Bill. Funny show. Great.
That's what he'd just started with.
No punctuation whatsoever whatsoever.
Hey, Bill. Funny show. Great. All right.
Maybe this guy's from overseas or maybe
he's down south and you can make it
thereby land. Who knows? He goes,
I have a question for your mm.
Podcasts.
My girlfriend,
who I've lived with for the last seven
years is starting to constantly ask me to
shave my chest. Oh, I went the other
way. Oh, you went the other way?
Um, I'm pretty hairy, but
not fucking Chewbacca Harry.
Just mainly my chest.
This is not a problem,
but sometimes she won't
have sex with me until I do.
Whoa. All right. That's, that's a,
okay. That's red flag number one for me.
Okay.
Unless you're, you're
not perceptive as to, uh,
how Harry your chest is a,
it can take over an hour
to properly to do properly.
And sometimes I can't be
fucked after a hard day's work,
so I just rub one out. I know times
change because in the 70s, Harry was sexy,
but now every pop stars dying
to look more like a woman.
I swear Justin Bieber is prettier than
half the women. I Bang. What do you think?
Um,
yeah,
that whole manscape looked I
guess is supposed to be in.
I have no idea. But um, I find it odd.
Okay.
I don't find it odd that you're,
you're
girlfriend is asking to uh, you know,
maybe trim down your chest a little bit,
but the fact that she won't
even have sex with you, um,
I dunno what happened.
Okay.
Did some pervert with the fucking
full full chest of hair fucking lay down
on top of her and do something to her.
Like that's kind of weird to me.
Like how do you think she would feel if
you were like, Hey, can you a, I dunno,
trim up here or there or I
literally can't have sex with you.
That's kind of fucked up. She's really
making you jump through some hoops there.
Um, so you're either way
hairier than you're letting on.
I get women being grossed
out by back here, you know,
especially those guys who have it like
up on their shoulders and then they just
have like the two patches just above
the kidney and just below the shoulder
blade. This, those two,
like they got, I dunno,
like they got hugged by someone
who jerked off too much.
Um, I would sit down with
her and just be like, listen,
I'm not going to say I'm not
going to fucking shape my chest,
but it's kind of weird
to me that if I don't,
you don't even find me sexually
attractive. I mean, what do you,
are you having sex with my
chest or you end to me. I mean,
I could see if this is a one night stand,
you're like, listen, I'm into this.
I'm not into that. Do this, do this. And
for the love of God, shut the fuck up.
All right. And you have your little
grocery list on how you need,
what you need me to do to get you there.
I get that.
But if I'm in a fucking relationship
with you, you know, that's,
that's kind of a, but you know,
you didn't really even ask that.
I don't even know what
the fuck he asked me. Um,
okay.
It takes you an hour to do it.
Don't they have like those fucking
things you can just kind of,
I know that's weird.
That's fucking weird to me.
I would, I would do, that
would be my biggest concern.
I would be asking her like what?
You can't even have sex with me?
I know what I understand on your face
because some women have sensitive skin,
you know, and when you know, if you're
on top of her missionary style hood,
you know, pumping away, if you're out of
shape, you land your head right down next.
You can get a little razor
burn other side of the face.
I understand that if you have like,
you have like a beard,
if you have whiskers,
I I fucking get that shit.
Can I just do that again
and I'm not going to do it.
Cause some people that it might hurt
your fucking ears. Um, I understand that.
But chest hair, why don't you,
why don't you come up with like a,
a compromise. Be like, all right,
how bout if my chest is to Harry,
we still bang. I just do it.
Doggy style. I promise. After
I get to where I need to go,
I won't collapse down on top of
you making you feel like, you know,
Burt Reynolds just got out of the
pool and is using you to towel off.
I won't do that.
Okay.
Maybe you could do or just sit down
with her and just be like, listen,
I'm not trying to be a dick here.
What is your issue with Harry Chess?
And uh, cause it's, you know,
I, you know, it's funny,
I'm getting more weirded
out by it by then. You are,
I'm probably putting bad ideas and he had,
so I'm just going to shut the fuck up.
I'm all right. Military history.
Ah, this is a great one. Hey,
grateful read. Ah, I love it.
Just when you think they've run out of
creative ways. Ah, that's a good one. Uh,
the past couple of shows you mentioned
you enjoy reading about World War II.
Just wanted to give you a
couple of recommendations.
First I'd like to mention,
uh, Oh, before he gets going.
I, I read that book a fly boys,
which I swear to God is not
about boy bands. It was by,
I forget who wrote it. Uh,
Jesus Christ on the worst, the same
day I did flags of our fathers, um,
wrote the same thing. Anyways, the past
couple of shows you mentioned blah, blah,
Blah books on World War II. Going to
give you a couple of recommendations.
First I'd like to mention
Dan Carlin's part podcast,
hardcore history. I'm telling you it's
right up your alley, dude. Good call.
I'm listening to that.
He's covered many aspects of history
from the bronze age to the relatively
modern age. If he can make the bronze
age, which I don't even know what that is.
Okay.
Like, uh, I, I can't
deal with it. You know,
you'll leave people I
can really read about.
Yeah.
From way back in the day,
which is basically anything before cowboys
and Indians is you have to be a mass
murdering psychopath. Like I can read
about these, the inquisitions, uh,
or the inquisition. I don't
fucking know if it's plural or not.
I agreed about that. Gaviscon
oh, I could read about, um,
Attila the hun.
Okay.
You know, basically the original scarfaces
I could read about those guys. And,
uh, but other shit, you know,
ancient medieval history and the fucking
Lilliputians we're going up against the
fucking, uh, Persian empire.
I don't, fuck, I, I dunno,
I can't deal with that shit. Um, so
if he can make that interesting, I,
I dunno, maybe I could listen to enough
of it and actually sound intelligent.
Who knows. So anyways, he says, uh,
but I suggest is series ghosts ghosts
of the the what does that asked front?
It's the mind blowing,
but little talked about conflict between
the Russians and the Germans. Yeah,
they really do skip over that.
Um,
in fact a lot of few people
don't live in this country.
A lot of what they talk about when World
War II, they do talk about Pearl Harbor,
which set the whole thing off,
but there's very,
they don't talk even about the Japanese
that much. It kind of Pearl Harbor. Uh,
they were winning at first battle of
midway and then we're dropping the two
fucking bombs and that's it.
And then you watch jaws and you hear
about the Indianapolis right signature and
may go into water.
Dad,
[inaudible] all we eat away to go
home. And that's how you learn. Right?
But they mainly talk about fighting
the Germans and mainly d day.
Hmm.
Basically from France going right
into German concentration camp,
Schindler's list. All right. Hitler killed
himself in the bunker game set match,
wipe your hands of it all right.
Then we're immediately into the Cold War.
But they also ignore, you know,
fighting the Germans in, in Africa,
uh,
fighting the Italians in Italy there and
how we went about it and all this stuff
that happened.
And uh,
yeah.
And then they certainly don't
talk about all we hear about the,
the Russians is basically they just
retreated and they drew them in and then
when the winter came,
they just mercilessly hacked them to
death all the way back to fucking Berlin.
That's all we hear.
I didn't know that they were just,
first of all,
as they were retreating,
they were blowing up their
own bridges and dams and just,
yeah.
Scorched scorched earth
thing that they did,
literally destroyed their
own fucking country.
So there was nothing there for the
Germans. It was fucking brilliant.
And absolutely fucking ruthless.
I would love, you know what,
that's something I'm going to do
on the rug. Thank you very much.
What a wonderful suggestion.
As I got to there.
Do you know what's great about those?
Both of those will make me more
informed and hopefully a better person.
Look at you guys paying it forward.
Maybe I can give somebody
some good advice there. Well,
let me just continue here
since incidentally I discovered
your podcast because
of him.
He was a guest on the Joe Rogan experience
and I started listening to Joe Rogan
regularly, which led me to your glorious
show. Oh, isn't that great? Yeah.
Rogin has done a lot for me. He
really has, when he hyped that, um,
that Yoko Ono thing I did,
that thing was like a year old and then
he talked about it and then that was it.
There was like a zillion people,
he's like the,
he has like Oprah Winfrey level power,
like were more than Oprah Winfrey said,
hey man, I don't think you should
be eating red meat anymore.
And all of Texas declared war on her
because she had that level of power.
That's what Rogan is.
It like the podcast world.
If that fucking guy says,
hey, check out this thing,
all of a sudden like it
gets a million hits. So, uh,
I got to do something for him. What,
what, what do you, what do you get?
What'd you get for Joe Rogan? I should
buy him a new pair of Mitts, you know,
by him as his fucking vitamins for the
week. Some sort of workout shit, not ana.
He has all of that stuff. I got to
go against the grain with Joe Rogan.
What should I, you know,
I'd buy him a nice son. Had,
you know,
really thoughtful gift like Joe,
I know you have everything that involves
choking somebody out or ending their
life if they fuck with you on any
level. You know, Bob on a nice sun had,
has anybody done anything to help keep
the sun out of that wonderful man's eyes?
I don't think they have.
And I think he's comfortable enough
with himself that he could accept the
unbelievably awkward, intimate moment of
me handing them that hat. You know what?
Next time I do is fucking podcast. I'm
bringing them a nice sun hat. You know,
I don't know. He might have
a convertible. Who knows?
Is there such a thing as a sun hat?
This is sun dress.
Then I just invent a new fucking hat.
There you go. People right there.
Look at me creating a whole new business,
creating jobs here at the Monday
morning podcast. Either way.
Listen to the Joe Rogan experience and
when you're done doing that, by the way,
uh,
me and Al Madrigal and some other,
a wonderful people have started
the all things comedy network.
If you like this podcast, if you'd
like to have a nice, incredible,
wide variety of podcasts,
listen to,
I suggest that you go to the all
things comedy podcast network and uh,
have listened Harlan Williams,
Tom Papa,
a baron Vaughn.
Tom Said Gara wow.
With the fucking, uh, we
got all kinds of people.
Your mom's house podcast there where
you'd think I would have them in front of
me. Minivan men. There's all kinds
of great one Harlan's highway.
All right,
here we go from a lady higher bill.
Hi a kid, uh, lady listener here.
I have two questions in one email.
I hope that's alright with you will.
Absolutely.
I'm just like that a woman actually is
listening to this podcast and wants to
contribute. I've been asking you guys
borderline begging you, you know,
to get out of the kitchen, figure out how
a computer works and send me an email.
But she just,
you know,
you're too busy making a sandwich
for the man in your life,
which is what you're supposed to do, you
know. But you know, every once in a while,
don't be afraid of the computer
ladies. Um, all right, lady.
Listen. Okay, the two questions,
the first one is about marriage.
I'm just wondering how
do you feel about it?
I'm only 18 and seeing what it is doing
to my parents recently is making me not
open to the idea in the future. Um,
all right, well this is the thing,
just because your parents don't
seem to have a happy marriage,
it doesn't mean that you
can't. All right. I think, uh,
if you go into to being married, married
for the right reasons, and if you're,
uh,
you're mature enough,
which I've never have been and I've been
a fucking complete piece of shit with
women and all that type of
stuff and I've been an APP
is your 20s are coming up.
Um,
you know, as your 20s
are coming up, you know,
you're going to meet some people that
you're going to look at and that you're
going to feel like you have a heart attack
and don't fucking walk away from the
go up to that person.
Just because your parents may be haven't
found true love doesn't mean you can't.
Eh, you know, you can find true love.
And then if you work at it and you
do the things you're supposed to do,
what you'll learn naturally
as you get older, you can
have a great time. You know?
Is there anything better than seeing
like two old people sitting together and
you can see they still have
that connection and they got to,
they literally enjoy life together.
What I wish I knew when I was younger,
how important that was.
You know,
I'm finally starting to see it through
all of my fucking horrific mistakes that
I've made in that category.
But like a
mmm.
I think you should be open to it.
You should be open to your 18
you should be open to things.
I'm not saying drug use and
being promiscuous and that
type of thing. Smartsheet.
I mean, uh, finding love. You
should definitely be open to
not happy, particularly your
parents. And you're like, well,
this just seems like a lot
of work to just be miserable.
MMM.
That doesn't mean you have to be
miserable. All right, there you go.
So there's just, that's
your first one. All right.
My second question she says is about
how and when one should introduce a
significant other to parents.
MMM.
Just to give you more information.
My boyfriend's 21 and in the last year
of college we've been together for about
a year and five months.
All right.
That's some scary math there
depending on what state you're in. Uh,
every time I am going to hang out with
him or have a sleep over at his house,
I've been making up an excuse.
Like I'm going to a concert that ends
really late going to stay with a friend.
I can't seem to work up the nerve
to tell either my mom or dad.
I am more worried about my dad
because he's a fucking big mouth.
The whole family would know by the
end of the night when he's drinking on
weekends.
He likes to bring up conversations just
to work on people's nerves in the house.
I don't want my boyfriend to be the topic
in the House for my dad to get on my
nerves with. So do I just go
with the, if it ain't broke,
don't fix it route and keep making shitty
excuses until they either find out on
their own or I move out of the house or
do I just work up some balls here and
tell them that I have a boyfriend?
Well they're gonna find out eventually
and when they find out you're not going
to have control over
the situation. So, um,
okay.
I kind of got lost there.
We you,
you make up excuses to your parents or
to your boyfriend. Let me go back here.
Micro.
Second question is Alba.
Okay.
How do I introduce my
boyfriend and my parents? Okay.
Every time I'm going to hang out
with him with sleep over his house,
I've been making up an excuse.
Oh, okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Uh, this is what I would do.
They are probably the more you say I'm
going to another concert that's going to
end like they're going to figure it
out. How do you introduce your parents?
Uh, do your boyfriend. I
would just, I would do this.
I wouldn't say shit to your parents other
than I have a boyfriend now and I want
to introduce him to you guys and I would
leave it at that because your parents
are your parents and they're
going to behave how they behave.
And then what I would do is I
would give a pregame speech to, uh,
to your boyfriend and be
like, look, I love my parents.
They're a little bit nuts.
And this is the thing too. You're
probably going to overreact, you know,
like the fear you have of what they're
going to do is going to be so much bigger
probably than what they're
actually going to do.
It's because they're your parents.
You want their approval and you
fucking hate them all at the same
and it's going to be like just
walking into a store like, hello sir,
can I help you? Yes. I like
that shirt. There you go.
That'll be nine 95. Thank you.
Goodbye. It's going to be at
that level a little bit more. Um,
it's just going to be nice. They just
going to be exchanging niceties. Okay.
That's what I'm predicting
is going to happen.
And then what's going to happen is
when he, when your boyfriend leaves,
he's going to tell you how nice your
parents are because why wouldn't you?
And then that's probably going to know
you want some level cause you're gonna be
like, no, they're fucking assholes.
You haven't had to live with them.
So don't do that to him either.
Um,
I would take control of the
situation and just introduce him.
MMM.
And if they ask how long you've been
seeing him, you know, when you first say,
I want you to introduce, I want it
to introduce my boyfriend to you.
And if they asked how long
you've been seeing him,
I don't know your dad's
drinks. And he says, Shit,
you might want to lie about that.
I Dunno, I'll fuck him if he does.
Don't lie to them.
Say about a year and five months.
And if they say, well why have you brought
him around? Just be like, well dad,
cause you have a tendency to get drunk
and talk about everybody's business in a
row is really, uh, made me
nervous. That's why I didn't,
you can't fuck with the truth.
Okay.
What's he going to say to that? I don't
get drunk and say all that type of shit.
I guess he could be in denial.
I don't know. At some point,
you know what you have to do.
You got to like you,
you got to man up or woman up and you
just have to live your fucking life and
you just have to understand that yeah,
your parents are your
parents to fucking awesome,
but they're just people and
you just really have to, uh,
in a, in a healthy weight,
not give a fuck what they think anymore
in a healthy way. Okay. I don't mean like,
like I said, go out and start doing
drugs and being a fucking idiot.
You should always care about not
bringing shame to your family name,
but like as far as that other stuff,
like I wanted you to be a doctor,
but you're going to fucking, I
dunno. Open your own bakery. The,
I'm so disappointed. Well,
be disappointed. Okay.
Cause I don't want to fucking sit there
vacuum and out somebody's ass or looking
at somebody's toes or working on a brain.
Whatever the fuck a doctor does,
I want to make pop tarts. All
right. That's gonna make me happy.
If you can't accept that, then I don't
want to tell you. All right people,
that is the podcast for this
week. I hope you enjoyed it. Um,
here's the big Ole wrap up here.
Now that show is over.
Don't forget to sign up for your raw.
What? Before I do the wrap up, let me, uh,
let me get some of my gigs.
Like is sending a, be it, uh,
it would be an El Paso this Thursday
nights, San Antonio Friday night,
the following weekend I'm
going to be in West Virginia,
Pittsburgh at the Heinz Theater,
and then I'm going to be up in Toronto,
Ontario at the just for
laughs festival and a,
the week after that I'm going to be doing
a two shows at the prestigious Chicago
Theater in where else? Chicago,
Illinois. That's what I got coming up.
All right. Then I know I got
up San Jose, Seattle, Arizona,
run in the beginning of October.
That's it. All right. Okay.
There you go. That's the podcast for
this week. If you like my comedy,
please download my special
off my podcast of mine.
I'm sorry if my website and if
you'd like a hard copy version,
you can also get that
makes a wonderful gifts,
especially for someone that you
don't really give a shit about,
but you have to get them a gift to
give them a fucking DVD. All right,
here's the wrap up everybody.
Now that the show's over,
don't forget to sign up for your free
trial of Hulu Plus Hulu plus such.
You binge on thousands of hit shows
anytime, anywhere on your TV, PC,
smartphone,
or tablet.
Support this podcast once again and get
an extended free trial of Hulu plus when
you go to the podcastPage@billboard.com
and Click on the Hulu plus banner or go
to Bill Burr or sorry,
or go to Hulu plus.com/bill once again,
that's Hulu plus.com/bill thank you
for listening. That's the podcast.
For this week. Go fuck yourselves
and, uh, I'll talk to you next week.